yeah but the coach have to deal with the  same Temptations in life that you or  anyone else yeah they're not like  protected from those Temptations you  just think after 20 30 years you'd have  some skill  if you're like 56 dude you're the path  of the preacher and then it's like you  have you have no skills built up none  they're like they're partying drinking  smoke I mean I'm not there's it's a  stereotype for a reason right right and  so then they're like well what skills  are you teaching here clearly not good  ones if you can't and I'm not saying  like I understand like it's probably  just an excuse to be a bad like you know  to not practice or whatever but that's  just how I see it